boah ich bin auch mal gespannt wie das
beste Handy aussieht warte ich schaue
mir das auch mal an 20 Sekunden später
du hast immer den gleichen
Gesichtsausdruck
ja herzlich willkommen erstmal hier zum
Stream ähm freut uns natürlich dass ihr
wieder am Start seid
sag mal was will das holen hinter dir
von dir
luca du hast mir doch dieses eine Huhn
hingesetzt im letzten Stream und es
verfolgt mich jetzt überall hin
weißt du du hast es doch mir gegeben
hast
[Musik]
let's go hey Laser ich komme nicht raus
Leute
Sandra zeig mal ganz kurz dein Schiff
korrekt das ist shift
Leute wir sind jetzt auf Ernst jetzt
richtig schon eine pilzbiom ne
ja und irgendwo hier weiß ich noch ja
hier guck mal hier war der dieses
Riesenloch weißt du noch wo wir schon
drin waren
wie hast du das jetzt gemacht
ich bin hier runtergesprungen warte ich
kann jetzt ich kann dir den größeren
Dings machen dann kannst du reinspringen
na warte Moment
ich brauche eine kleine Fläche okay
kannst
[Musik]
einfach nur ins Wasser rein ich meine
das ist jetzt auch nicht irgendwie ein
Wassereimer sondern das sind ja
sehr echt schon eigentlich ist relativ
groß
[Musik]
sehr gut
hier sind alles noch Sachen von dir oh
das ist ein Schild das kann ich nehmen
warte
ja oh mein Gott Leute oh mein Gott
der Plan ist Leute dass wir hier jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen Ärzte haben und
dann
kommt in Richtung Hölle bewegen auch
nicht weiß ist dass ich hier
Spinnennetze brauche ja also ich hole
die Spinnennetze nicht dafür dass ich
ähm so gern was mit Spinnennetzen bauen
möchte das ist schon für einen prank
gedacht
schlagen und dann blocken
[Musik]
nicht
wie heißt deine Frisur ich will auch
gemobbt werden
[Musik]
man könnte immer aufhören nur wenn meine
Haare zu reden
[Musik]
ich habe es irgendwie schon kommen sehen
ehrlich gesagt ich auch Sandy was
brauchst du an Rüstung chillig dass du
Bescheid sagst
ich wusste dass du hier warst ich habe
aber schon verteidigt und beide
verteidigt sehr gut super ich bin wieder
oben komm hoch wie
ja ich bin wieder ganz oben
aber warum ich dachte wir gehen noch ein
bisschen in die Höhle wir haben genug
von unseren Sachen ja eigentlich also
wir könnten schon reinhauen wollte für
mich was eh nur wichtig Eisen zu holen
das haben wir und äh die Spinnennetze
für den prank den nicht geplant habe und
dazu kommen wir jetzt auch gleich ich
bin nur einmal verreckt leute leute habt
ihr gehört brombe hat einfach
nur geändert ja Brombeeren
[Musik]
Homberg
werden wir um 5 Euro ein paar Sekunden
später
was heißt PayPal
[Musik]
ja jetzt
würde ich sagen wenn du irgendwas zu tun
hast kannst du es mal eben machen weil
ich brauche jetzt ein bisschen für die
Vorbereitung und für den prank den ich
jetzt vorbereitet was was darf ich bin
jetzt beim verzauberungstisch ach so
einfach reinlegen immer wieder raus
nicht in dem Verzauberung zwischen die
Kiste da links neben
welche Kiste
[Musik]
nein
bist du blind
hier in die Kiste legen
die das ist keine Kiste
das hier oben ja so Leute und ich
bereite jetzt meinen prank vor
[Musik]
was machst du gerade
die ganzen Tiere bringen was machst du
ich habe hier was gefunden ich weiß aber
nicht ob ich mich hier waren so eine
Kiste und Leute meinten dass nicht
willst mal kurz herkommen ich habe
nämlich eigentlich hier gerade was bauen
wollen an unserem Häuschen
aber wo soll ich genau hin nee komm mal
rechts hier komm mal zum
pferdestallieren dann zeige ich dir das
[Musik]
weil das Problem ist das ist so eine
Truhe du kennst ja manchmal das so
Sachen spawnen so Portale oder Dörfer
oder irgendwie sowas oder diese
Minenschacht wo wir vorhin drin waren
und so weißt du
sowas konnte ja auch so wie hier Dörfer
spawnen ist das nie aufgefallen wir
haben da vorne
öffnen die mal hier kann man hier sieht
die für dich irgendwie komisch aus wenn
du dich hier hinstellt
guck mal da rein
[Musik]
wo ist mein ganzes Inventar
holen ich will jetzt nicht reinlaufen
[Musik]
spring einfach mal darunter die Items
alle da unten
[Musik]
das gibt die fetteste Kampf an dein Haus
wird brennen
[Musik]